c'est officiel la grande bretagne compte
deux célibataires de moins la france lui
accorde l'asile politique à condition
free ne parle pas politique
la pénurie devient insupportable les
manifestations se multiplient l'été
existe alain gillot-pétré elle a
rencontré
bonsoir charles et diana sont donc
mariés femme en quittant cet après-midi
de palais de buckingham et ils ont été
acclamés par des milliers de londoniens
la joie de la foule a été à la mesure du
phase de cette cérémonie que 750
millions de téléspectateurs ont pu
suivre dans le monde entier une journée
aux allures de conte de fées comme l'a
dit lui-même l'archevêque de cambrai
dans son homélie
toutes les conditions étaient donc
réunies pour que la fête soit très belle
avec ses carrosses l'émotion de la reine
et ce matin dans la cathédrale saint
paul les larmes de charles et le sourire
de son épouse
il est 10 heures 14 dans la cathédrale
de sainte rose quand le prince charles
parce l'anneau au doigt de sa femme lady
derrière en effet la coutume anglicane
stipule que seule la femme doit porter
l'alliance celle ci provient d'un lagon
du pays de galles nous ont déjà été
tirés et les alliances de la reine-mère
de la reine de la princesse margaret et
de la princesse anne et puis dans un
moment d'intense émotion il prononcera
son serment demain à charles philippe
artur jorge je te prends toi derrière la
française pourrait pour te garder pour
le meilleur et pour le pire
jean la richesse et dans la pauvreté
dans la maladie et la bonne santé pour
t'aimer et de chérir jusqu'à ce que la
mort nous sépare conformément à cette
loi de dieu ainsi à tottenham
et puis c'est probablement le moment le
plus émouvant de la cérémonie
karim que vous entendez dédié à la
mémoire
quel charme a toujours beaucoup aimé et
qui fut assassiné par l'armée
républicaine irlandaise
il s'agit bien entendu de sans lui
mon but pour clore la cérémonie
c'est là qu'ils chuchotent quant aux
garrigues qui prononcera la bénédiction
des faits récents gaye 2 in show and
peace un blessé corot micky fabas à
hambach dispute
750 millions de téléspectateurs seront
les témoins du bonheur de lady diana
princesse de galles puisque c'est ainsi
qu'un seul homme à sa sortie de la
cathédrale
ils sont plus de 100 milles à kameni
toutes leurs précieux à sa cause et ils
seront plus de 300 millions amassés
devant pas qui comparaissent pour leur
souhaiter bonne chance
vers 15h35 gmt le couple arrive à la
gare de wenzhou afin d'entamer un voyage
de noces à l'abri des yeux indiscrets
ils iront rejoindre le yacht de la
famille royale bretagne à qui les
enverra vers gibraltar
certains verront dans le faste
occasionnés par cette cérémonie un
gâchis incroyable de ressources
financières et humaines
ils n'ont peut-être pas tout à fait tort
mais il nous oublie trop facilement
qu'un tel événement film marché des
affaires et que de telles images rapport
beaucoup de vies et dans un monde où
domine la violence la peur et l'angoissé
qui le chiffre air son juste prix le
plaisir de prendre à y prendre part
intel compte deux filles et comme les
anglais aiment à le dire élèves appelés
erreurs
et bien précisément à l'occasion de ce
mariage la presse britannique s'est
interrogé sur la monarchie et sur ses
coutumes pour le final sur le times le
mariage représente la survie de la
couronne
et puis pour le times le jour du mariage
appartient aussi à la nation
il semble bien en effet qu'une majorité
de britanniques tiennent à réaffirmer
leurs différences ou leurs spécificités
en ovationnant ainsi la famille royale
mais il ya aussi des contestataires
dominique torrès nous rapporte
l'ambiance qui a régné aujourd'hui en
grande bretagne pendant des milliers de
spectateurs se bousculer ce matin dans
la rue pour apercevoir le cortège
certains privilégiés se tasser aux
fenêtres les places de choix à pied
chaque fois denis 500 francs 1050 francs
pour la joie de partager un coin de
naître avec 50 autres touristes
excusez-moi de quel pays venez vous de
colombie en amérique du sud
je suis venue spécialement pour voir le
mariage j'étais déjà venu voir le
couronnement de la reine elizabeth
parce que j'adore la famille royale je
passe mon temps à collectionner leurs
photos livres tout ce qui paraît sur eux
mais vous faites cela pour toutes les
familles royales tout mais surtout pour
la famille royale anglaise tout le
royaume uni n'était pas en liesse
aujourd'hui la nuit dernière et très tôt
ce matin des affrontements ont eu lieu à
liverpool entre plusieurs centaines de
policiers et des manifestants
plusieurs vestes et des deux côtés une
véritable bataille rangée s'est déroulée
aux premières heures de cette matinée
colère également et résignation aussi
dans les quartiers catholiques de
belfast
traumatisé par le jeune et sans doute
par la mort très prochaine des deux
grévistes de la faim de la prison de
metz cette journée de mariage aurait été
l'occasion pour le président de la
république française d'avoir des
contacts politiques importants dans la
capitale anglaise
ce matin françois mitterrand s'est
entretenu avec le général ian s le
président de la république portugaise le
chef de l'état français a précisé à son
interlocuteur que l'entrée du portugal
dans la communauté économique européenne
imposait à la france un problème sérieux
notamment en ce qui concerne les
produits agricoles méditerranée
puis le chef de l'état a déjeuné avec
madame thatcher avant de la rencontrer
une nouvelle fois cet après midi pour
une entrevue en tête à tête
jean-marc il use nous fait le compte
rendu de toute cette journée du
président de la république
loin du fracas du cortège royal et de
l'enthousiasmé populaire on l'a bien sûr
aussi discuter politique une heure de
tête à tête ici à downing street cet
après midi entre margaret thatcher et
françois mitterrand dont c'était
véritablement le premier entretien
approfondi
bien sûr on s'était rencontré à
luxembourg on s'est revu à ottawa mais
chaque fois de manière brève
on dit que les rapports personnels sont
très bons d'ailleurs souvenez-vous à
ottawa madame thatcher avait confié sur
le mode badin qu'elle aimerait bien que
son l'opposition travailliste partagent
les options du président socialiste en
matière de défense par exemple une
manière de souligner qu'en dépit des
différences de conception économique
rien ne peut nuire à la bonne
coopération politique entre londres et
paris
alors aujourd'hui on se sera surtout
livré un tour d'horizon général après le
sommet de tahoua avant de renouer bien
sûr avec des questions plus strictement
européenne le problème le plus aigu et
en celui de la politique agricole
commune
vous savez que les anglais on souhaite
la réforme
je ne pense pas pour autant que le
hareng ou le mouton européen et figurer
en très bonne place au menu
car ces conversations risque d'abord à
préparer le sixième sommet
franco-britannique qui se déroulera à
londres le 10 et le 11 septembre
prochain
une surprise de taille ce matin avec
l'arrivée en france de l'ancien
président iranien bani sadr très tôt un
boeing 707 transportant monsieur bani
sadr se poser sur la base militaire
d'evreux après avoir survolé la turquie
chypre la grèce et l'italie
et quelques minutes plus tard on
apprenait que la france accordé l'asile
politique à l'ancien président édouard
et au dessus de la base militaire
d'evreux à son bord l'ancien président
bani sadr accompagné d'un colonel d'un
ami personnel du président qui
organisait sa fuite depuis téhéran même
non
j'ai déposé hier matin un plan de vol
tout à fait régulier un vol
d'entraînement auprès des autorités
militaires
deux heures avant le décollage nous
avons emmené clandestinement
monsieur bani saad à bord de l'appareil
et nous avons décollé normalement
nous avons ensuite mis le cap sur la
turquie en volant à basse altitude pour
échapper aux radars 9h30 enfreint un
convoi quitte evreux en direction de
paris encadrés d'un service de sécurité
exceptionnelles le président banny sade
vient d'obtenir le droit d'asile
politique en france
le convoi sera ensuite directement à
cachan dans la banlieue parisienne où
résident déjà l'une de ses filles et où
depuis quelques jours la sécurité a été
considérablement renforcée
un homme souriant il y blement très
détendue
bon jeudi dans ses droits y est je sais
c'est en france le cervia d'adhérents
par avion militaire de la base aérienne
de terrain j'essaie toujours un terrain
je reste ici en france puisque le jour
où le peuple ouvrira le chemin de la
démocratie et aura une vie politique
digne de ce nom
non je pense que les événements
je sais la résistance populaire surtout
l'abstention aux élections de mai via
une semaine manque vous que le peuple
ait décidé à résister à continuer dans
la jument de sa révolution jusqu'à la
victoire finale
pourquoi pas choisi la france j'ai passé
une bonne part de ma vie et si en france
et qui sont ici évoquer son protégé le
président votre dame où vous cachez vous
venir en jeu des bagages était attirant
2 jours vous étiez caché à téhéran dans
téhéran même je t'ai toujours là terrain
cacher on peut pas dire parce que je
circulais jeux et activités je faisais
des communiqués comme des activités
politiques mais couverts par le peuple
vous ne vivez pas d'être arrêté donc
vous voyez j'ai choisi un chemin très
dangereux pour montrer que si je suis
ici c'est pour encourager la résistance
de mon père c'est donc à cacher au sud
de paris que monsieur bani sadr s'est
installée c'est là qu'il avait vécu la
plupart de ses années d'exil sous le
règne du shah et elle a également comme
il l'a dit que vivent et ses deux filles
nous retrouvons philippe rochot akasha à
dispositif policier très important a été
mis en place ce soir autour de
l'immeuble où réside monsieur bani sadr
on craint d'abord des manifestations
d'opposants ou de partisans de l'ancien
président de la république islamique
et puis on craint aussi des attentats
comme celui qui avait failli coûter la
vie
l'année dernière à neuilly à monsieur
chapour bakhtiar l'ancien premier
ministre du shah monsieur bani sadr
réside ici ce soir au premier étage de
cet immeuble avec notamment le pilote
qui l'a amené jusqu'à evreux avec
également monsieur salama tian l'un de
ses plus proches collaborateurs et puis
surtout avec monsieur massoud radjavi
l'ancien chef de l'extrême gauche
iranienne les moudjahidine du peuple à
plusieurs reprises aujourd'hui la france
a demandé à monsieur bani sadr de
s'abstenir de toute activité politique
sur notre pays une condition qu a
rappelé claude cheysson ministre des
relations extérieures interviewé dès ce
matin par daniel bani sadr l'ancien
président n'est plus bas nous demandent
l'asile politique ainsi que quatre de
ses compagnons il vient de lui être
accordé naturellement bani sadr a été
invité à reconnaître formellement qui
n'avait le droit à aucune déclaration
politique qu'une action politique en
france et à partir de la france
ceci a été reconnu formellement par bani
sadr qui a même signé un document à cet
égard est ce que ça ne va pas compliquer
nos relations un peu plus encore avec
l'iran beaucoup de choses compliquées
mais voulait ou pour autant que de
fouler aux pieds les les libertés
politiques et le droit d'asile
certainement pas aussi une ministre est
ce qu'on peut vous demander dans quelles
conditions se sont engagés les pour
parer pour aboutir à cette décision
il n'y a pas eu le moindre pourparlers
nous avons appris avec surprise je dois
dire à 4h15 du matin qu'un avion iranien
se présentait dans l'espace aérien
français demandait le droit d'y pénétrer
et d'y atterrir comme c'était un avion
militaire
il a été immédiatement envoyés sur une
base militaire française la balle
d'hébreu et c'est à ce moment là que le
gouvernement était prévenu de la faire
et qui a naturellement dit que s'il y
avait des demandes d'asile politique
l'asile politique serait accordée comme
on pouvait s'y attendre le gouvernement
iranien réclame l'extradition de
monsieur bani sadr qui l'accusent
d'avoir détourné l'avion avec lequel il
est venu à paris pendant un certain
temps ce matin au
ministère des relations extérieures on
s'est un peu inquiété de savoir si ce
n'était pas le cas si monsieur banny ça
n'avait pas employer la force pour
détourner l'avion avec lequel il est
venu et ce qui aurait constitué un acte
de piraterie internationale pour lequel
l'extradition va presque automatiquement
être de droit heureusement ce n'est pas
le cas et monsieur bani sadr ne sera pas
extradé
cela dit il est évident que les
relations franco iraniennes ont pour le
moins se rafraîchir ou se tendre dans
les jours qui viennent et on ne peut
s'empêcher de penser à un précédent où
quelque chose qui ressemble à un
précédent lorsque les états unis ont
accordé le droit d'asile au shah d'iran
et ont refusé son extradition
les ide les étudiants islamiques se sont
emparés de l'ambassade américaine à
téhéran et ont pris les diplomates
américains en otage tout ce qu'on peut
espérer c'est que l'histoire dans une
situation assez analogue ne se répétera
pas oui je reçois en provenance de
londres la première déclaration de
françois mitterrand sur cette affaire là
voici une personnalité étrangère
hier encore chefs d'état demandent asile
pour protéger sans doute sa vie la
france est ouverte à ce qu'elles
souhaitent sous bénéfice du respect de
notre de nos propres lois donc dit
monsieur mitterrand alors qu'il était
encore à notre il est temps maintenant
de rappeler le rôle joué par l'ancien
président bani sadr qui arrivent en
france je vous le rappelle après un mois
et demi de clandestinité dans son propre
pays
jacquat bouchard l' affaire des otages
aura été l'un des défis lancés à
monsieur bani sadr avant même son
accession à la présidence de la
république
tout au long de la campagne ils sortent
déjà aux intégristes religieux
il est leur bête noire peine perdue pour
ses adversaires bani saad est élu
président le 26 janvier 80 avec 75% des
suffrages
bani sadr apparaît alors comme le fils
spirituel du guide suprême de l'iran
l'ayatollah comédie
malgré sa popularité le nouveau
président ne peut être empêché la
victoire des religieux aux élections
législatives de février 80 très vite
d'ailleurs c'est la crise l'épreuve de
force
et après 15 mois de guérilla politique
la destitution de monsieur bani sadr le
22 juin dernier par commenee il se
réfugie dans la clandestinité et annonce
la création d'un conseil national de la
résistance
je ne quitterai pas l'iran déclarent
alors l'ex président un mois plus tard
il est pourtant contraint de prendre le
chemin de l'exil première question
chaque à bush a reçu bani sadr a déclaré
à plusieurs reprises que la fin du
régime iranien a été proche alors le
pensez vous y pensez vous que
l'événement d'aujourd'hui peut avoir un
rôle déterminant dans ce complexe alors
écouter tout ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que la situation en iran est très très
mauvaise
la guerre se poursuit avec l'irak il ya
des millions de réfugiés la situation
économique est catastrophique
80% de la population active est frappé
par le chômage et enfin surtout l'iran
est rentré dans ce cycle de la terreur
et de la répression
souvenez-vous de l'attentât qu'il ya
quelques semaines avait fait 73 morts
parmi les hauts dignitaires du régime
depuis ne se passe pas de jour sans
qu'il y ait dix à quinze exécution par
le présicent ferraille n apparaît assez
divisés aujourd'hui effectivement on
peut dire qu'il ya trois grandes bourg
broc ce mode il ya trois branches si
vous voulez dans l'opposition iranienne
il ya des monarchies ce qui reste fidèle
au pas la vie au chat il y a disons les
centristes et modérés du type bastia et
il y a l'opposition de gauche celle qui
aujourd'hui mène le combat armé en iran
alors il ya une réaction aujourd'hui de
monsieur bakhtiar tout à fait négative
monsieur bakker qui vous savez a été le
dernier premier ministre du chah
il déclare qu'il n'est pas question
d'établir un front commun avec monsieur
banny salle puisque monsieur banny saad
a servi au plus haut niveau le régime
que monsieur bahtiyar combat
une autre déclaration monsieur alia
munich qui fut lui aussi premier
ministre du chah lui alors au contraire
salué comme une bonne nouvelle l'arrivée
en france de l'ancien président et il
préconise la formation d'un gouvernement
de réconciliation nationale niro
toujours où s'est produit la nuit
dernière un tremblement de terre qui
aurait provoqué la mort de quatre mille
personnes dans la province de kerman au
sud est du pays au mois de juin dernier
dans cette même région un séisme avait
déjà provoqué la mort de 3000 personnes
la crise syro-israéliennes rebondi
aujourd'hui avec la destruction d'un
avion militaire syrien par des chasseurs
israéliens le premier ministre israélien
menahem begin a déclaré qu'israël était
obligé de poursuivre ses vols au dessus
du territoire libanais tout simplement
pour voir ce qui s'y passait situation
très tendue également en pologne où
s'étend le mouvement de protestation
contre la pénurie alimentaire gens
offraient d'autres oui effectivement
depuis quelques semaines la pologne est
vraiment au bord de la disette et la
situation est en train de prendre un
tour très dramatique puisque on assiste
depuis quelques jours à ce qu'il faut
bien appeler des véritables émeutes de
la faim et ce sont les ménagères qui
descend de même maintenant dans la rue
pour protester contre le manque de
ravitaillement et il y à des accusations
qui sont sous tendus par ces
manifestations ont dit qu'il y a des
stockages quelque part qu'on veut
véritablement affamer la population
alors la fameuse alliance des forces de
la raison qui a été appelée au congrès
par monsieur cagna entre solidarité qui
représente la société polonaise et le
gouvernement est bien est en train
peut-être en cette fin juillet début du
mois d'août
de montrer qu'elle ne pourra pas se
réaliser parce que on est vraiment dans
une situation très très grave et je
voudrais dire un point sur lequel on
n'existe peut-être pas assez c'est le
courant des migrations qui se passe à
l'heure actuelle de pologne des gens
partent et en france à l'heure actuelle
il y a près de deux mille polonais qui
sont là il y en a quatre mille hollande
il en a huit mille ans les laisse partir
facilement
oui parce que maintenant ils ont obtenu
des passeports pour partir pendant une
durée d'un an et les visas de sortie on
arrive à les allées les avoirs et soul
et l'esprit notamment des jeunes qui
partent c'est de dire on va venir
travailler
et puis gagner un peu d'argent la visite
de gaston defferre à madrid le ministre
de l'intérieur et de la décentralisation
est arrivé en espagne au moment où le
climat entre les deux pays s'est quelque
peu détériorée ces dernières semaines
ce voyage prévu le 21 juillet avait été
reportée à la demande des autorités
espagnoles
après les déclarations de monsieur de
fer sur les militants basques jean louis
le sel pour gaston defferre c'était
aujourd'hui la journée des contretemps a
madrid on a tout fait pour que le
ministre de l'intérieur français ne
rencontre pas la presse surtout pas la
presse espagnole qu'il avait vilipendé
on s'en souvient à semaine dernière
après ses déclarations dans les colonnes
du nouvel observateur
alors on l'a fait atterrir sur un
aérodrome militaire pour éviter tout
contact
on l'a conduit immédiatement au
ministère de l'intérieur espagnol dont
il est ressorti que plus de quatre
heures après en contrepartie gaston
defferre a insisté pour rencontrer
felipe gonzalez le leader du ps espagnol
ce qui n'était pas du goût mais pas du
tout du gouvernement de madrid
résultat une heure et demie de retard
sur l'horaire en fait c'est que malgré
cette visite éclair la venue de monsieur
de faire à madrid n'a pas changé d'un
iota
les positions entre paris et madrid on a
simplement mieux compris du côté
français la position espagnole qui est
de ne pas admettre que le terrorisme
basque puisse être ou apparaître comme
un frein à la démocratie à la jeune
démocratie espagnole
mais du côté espagnol on a mieux
accepter la position française
peut être parce que monsieur de fer a
fait remarquer qu'il n'y avait en tout
et pour tout que 12 demande
d'extradition formulée à l'heure
actuelle simplement on à accepter
davantage de concertation entre les
polices française et espagnole
les questions juridiques comme celle des
extraditions les questions juridiques
c'est au ministre de la justice de les
régler at on dit
d'ailleurs le ministre de la justice
espagnol viendra prochainement en france
pour tenter à son tour de régler le
contentieux et le contentieux important
qui existe aujourd'hui entre madrid et
paris
les importations de fruits de légumes
espagnols tout comme les importations de
vins italiens sont de plus en plus
boycotté par des comités d'action de
producteurs et même par des commandos de
viticulteurs ce double dossier agricole
fera l'objet d'une communication demain
au conseil des ministres
edith cresson a reçu aujourd'hui des
représentants de ces professions ainsi
que des parlementaires nationaux et
européens du parti communiste christian
mary mona
après les élus socialistes se sont donc
les parlementaires communistes du midi
qui ont été reçus au ministère de
l'agriculture
au menu des conversations le vin italien
et les fruits et légumes espagnols ce
qui concerne les importations des fruits
un accord entre la france et l'espagne
est intervenue et pour une durée
indéterminée une mesure qui devrait
éviter ces actions de commandos de la
semaine dernière côté viticulteurs on se
plaint de la baisse du pouvoir d'achat
les charges ont augmenté de 20% et le
vin se vend toujours au même prix
l'accélération des importations de vins
italiens a mis le feu aux poudres avec
un rythme de 800 mille hectolitres par
mois et un prix intérieurs au vin
français mais la création des comités
d'action par département qui
contrôleront les importations et surtout
la réunion demain une cellule de gestion
de crise permettent au gouvernement de
disposer la sursis d'un mois le ministre
confirmera demain professional sa
volonté d'imposer à prix minimum à
bruxelles
n'oublions pas que le monde viticole
reste mobilisée sans décision rapide et
camions devraient connaître de sérieuses
difficultés de circulation comme celui
ci est les viticulteurs ont même précisé
que les touristes se souviendront
peut-être de leur retour de vacances à
la fin du mois d'août
le conseil des ministres toujours
examinera demain les propositions en
matière d'énergie et notamment la
suspension des travaux dans plusieurs
chantiers de centrales nucléaires les
ouvriers de la centrale nucléaire de
nogent sur seine ont protesté ce matin
contre l'arrêt vente ul des travaux
puisque je vous parle du problème
énergétique et bien sachez qu une
prochaine hausse du prix de l'essence
pourrait intervenir bientôt puisque le
comité des prix convoqué pour vendredi
le litre de super dépasserait les quatre
francs
on nous dit ce soir au ministère que
cette intervention n'interviendrait pas
cette augmentation n'interviendrait pas
avant le 5 août satisfaction à elf
aquitaine après l'opération du rachat de
la société pétrolière américaine texas
golfe
il s'agit en effet de la plus grosse
offre publique d'achat réussi pour une
société étrangère aux états unis l'opr
d'elf aquitaine sur texas gueule ce
n'est pas vraiment la conquête de
l'amérique mais c'est un pari difficile
gagner par albin chalandon
le patron du groupe d'états c'est la
première fois qu'une entreprise
étrangère avale un aussi gros morceau du
business américain texas gueule réalise
5 milliard et demi de francs de chiffre
d'affaires
elf a gagné en une seule manche du 26
juin au 27 juillet rachetant 35 millions
d'actions texas gulf c'est à dire plus
de la moitié du capital le reste des
actions devrait bientôt lui revenir 37%
cédé par une société canadienne et 13%
racheté par la suite coût de l'opération
environ 13 milliards de francs
à noter qu'elle sera essentiellement
financés par des emprunts à l'étranger
quant à l'intérêt de l'opéra il est
évident en se déployant aux états unis
elf aquitaine trouve une troisième
source de bénéfices après le gisement de
lacq et sa filiale au gabon texas gulf
en effet à dégager 1 milliard 800
millions de francs de bénéfices l'an
dernier c'est à dire environ 30% de son
chiffre d'affaires cette opération n'a
été possible que grâce à l'aval de
l'état
elf aquitaine est en effet une
entreprise nationale et d'une certaine
façon elle est déjà ce que vont devenir
les fameux groupe national is able pour
la première fois le pdg d'elf aquitaine
albin chalandon explique ce qu'est pour
lui la liberté d'action d'une entreprise
nationale
albin chalendon à ma thèse a toujours
été que il y a que de bonnes et
mauvaises entreprises elles peuvent être
à capitaux publics ou à capitaux privés
il y à des entreprises qui sont gérés de
façon dynamique d'autres qui ne le sont
pas de cette façon-là
et l'important c'est que les dirigeants
d entreprise quelle qu'elle soit est une
liberté d'action et puisse exercer
pleinement leurs responsabilités alors
le danger dans les entreprises qui
appartiennent au secteur public
c'est qu'elles soient transmises si je
puis dire à la pression d'administration
au contrôle de l'état
alors ce que j'ai beaucoup apprécié
dans le déroulement récent de cette
affaire c'est justement la liberté
d'action qui nous intervenus et la
pleine responsabilité dont nous avons pu
jouer un tour d'horizon aujourd'hui
entre le premier ministre pierre mauroy
et henri krasucki pour la cgt une
entrevue sérieuse et constructive a dit
monsieur krasucki le secrétaire
confédéral de la cgt a indiqué qu'il
subsistait des lacunes dans les avancées
sociales notamment en ce qui concerne la
réduction du temps de travail problèmes
économiques et problème de société
également dans un rapport effectué la
demande de nicole questiaux le ministre
de la solidarité nationale un rapport le
rose gras fuck que vous avez lu et
soigneusement et vous allez constater
que ce rapport était plein de choses
plein de choses passionnantes sur les
inégalités en france vient ce rapport
oui le voilà il est préparé par madame
blum girardot pour le miz solidarité
nationale et c'est en fait un constat
qu'on s'assure les inégalités en france
un constat sur le rôle de la rue
distribution un constat sur les effets
de la crise alors ils révèlent que les
inégalités en france sont importantes
notamment dans le domaine des salaires
par exemple le salaire d'un ouvrier est
égal à et trois fois cinq fois inférieur
à celui d'un cadre supérieur est ce que
c'est pareil dans tous les pays non les
inégalités sont plus forte en france et
en italie que dans les autres pays
européens par exemple
et puis il ya aussi une inégalité des
chances le rapport fait par exemple une
comparaison entre la fils d'ouvrier
affiche de cadres supérieurs à la
naissance de fils d'ouvriers a deux fois
plus de chances de mourir avant un an à
l'école
le fils d'ouvrier à 4 % de chances
d'accéder à l'enseignement supérieur
le fils du cadre supérieure à 72 % de
chance devant l'amour les champs sont
aussi inégal l'ouvrier meurent en
moyenne à 70 ans
le cadre supérieur meurent en moyenne à
78 qu'il n'ya pas certaine correction
contre ces inégalités
effectivement il ya une redistribution
qui est due notamment à la sécurité
sociale à l'impôt à l'assurance chômage
mais quelquefois cette modification joue
à contre sens un exemple la santé les
milieux aisés ce soit une mieux que les
autres dont ils profitent plus la
sécurité sociale ou bien le quotient
familial vous savez qui est établi sur
l'impôt sur le revenu en fonction du
nombre d'enfants bien il avantage les
plus riches c'est ce que la crise
accentue cette
situation la crise accentue cette
situation parce qu'elle a rendu une
partie de la population plus fragiles
les gens fragiles et bien c'est ce
qu'ils sont en dessous du smic ils sont
à peu près un million c'est les
apprentis les jeunes travailleurs les
gens qui travaillent moins de 40 heures
et puis il est aussi les gens qu'il ya
des gens qui ont des emplois précaires
les travailleurs intérimaires
les gens qui ont des contrats à durée
déterminée
il ya aussi les chômeurs alors l'idée
que les adresses des allocations de
chômage
encourage les gens à rester chômeurs je
crois que c'est vraiment une idée fausse
ce rapport le montre puisque un
cinquième des chômeurs inscrits ne
reçoivent rien comme allocation 1/5
reçoivent moins de 600 francs et les
trois quarts d'entre eux sont obligés de
faire des restrictions et même des
restrictions alimentaires laurent c'est
ce que ce rapport présente des choses
concrètes fait des propositions et bien
c'est un constat et ne donne pas de
remède ce qu'il peut exprimer par la
définition même des problèmes bien c'est
une volonté politique la volonté de s'y
attaquer les députés ne sont pas près de
partir en vacances
le débat sur le projet de loi de
décentralisation reprendra demain il
faut a dit pierre mauroy aujourd'hui que
les députés avaient jusqu'au bout le
premier ministre a souligné que lorsqu
on commençait à travailler bien il
fallait le terminer l'assemblée
nationale a adopté définitivement ce
matin la suppression de la cour de
sûreté de l'état
les interpellations se multiplient dans
la sphère auriol plusieurs personnes la
nuit dernière à marseille ainsi que le
responsable niçois du sac
et puis un homme dans les vosges par
ailleurs jacques chirac a démenti
aujourd'hui que finaux piety inculpé
dans la sphère lui servi de chauffeur à
l'occasion d'un voyage à marseille
la journée a commencé par un coup de
filet à marseille et sa région les
hommes de la pj ont interpellé au petit
matin une dizaine de membres du sac et
de sympathisants de l'organisation
ils ont été placés en garde à vue et
sont toujours interrogées à l'hôtel de
police ainsi que le responsable niçois
du service d'action civique charles
jules qui a été conduit cet après midi à
marseille par la gendarmerie
pourquoi avoir interpellé ces hommes
d'abord à cause d'un 10/10 vers
recueillies soit dans la maison du trim
auriol soit dans la voiture de jacques
massié retrouvé dimanche à nans les pins
soit à la suite de recoupements dans les
interrogatoires des cinq inculpés
quoi qu'il en soit leurs liens avec le
sac est évident c'est ce qu'ont déclaré
les enquêteurs ils sont presque persuadé
également
de tenir dans le lot certains des
membres du commando et peut-être même
les trois hommes qui leur manquent à
l'hôtel de police en tout cas tous les
services planchent sur la sphère et les
interrogatoires semblaient avancer bon
train certains policiers ont même quitté
marseille pour par hélicoptère avec un
hélicoptère de la gendarmerie pour se
rendre dans la région de saint zacharie
et de nans-les-pins là précisément ont
été trouvés et le corps de jacques
massié et sa voiture la voiture qu'il
conduisait le jour de sa mort sachez
encore que pierre de viser le secrétaire
national du sac
inculpé de complicité d'homicide et
incarcéré aux baumettes a été entendu
aujourd'hui par le juge françoise guérin
à sa demande sans doute son avocate
denise me allou était-elle pressé de
préciser les charges retenues contre son
client
relativement mince semble-t-il ceci
avant qu'ils soient confrontés avec les
autres inculpés mais cette journée a
aussi été celle du recueillement loin de
l'effervescence marseillaise la famille
massier a enterré l'inspecteur assassiné
dans son village d'origine à charleval
près d'aix en provence
une cérémonie d'une grande sobriété mais
où régne est aussi une grande tension
les hommes du groupe d'intervention de
la police nationale étaient présents
pour protéger marina mathier et sa
famille sans transition les prochains
départs en vacances dès la fin de la
semaine avec un nouveau cri d'alarmé de
bison futé il est très clair ne parte et
surtout pas samedi
car vous êtes près de 3 millions à
vouloir prendre la route ce jour là et
vise au futé vous promet des bouchons
historique
les pronostics de pierrette brès pour le
quarté de demain à enghien le 14 le neuf
le 1 le 12 le 13 le 6 le 4 et le 16 les
résultats du loto maintenant il fallait
jouer le 9 le 13 le 19 le 27
le 42 le nombre et sur les ardennes
l'après midi mais rien de bien méchant
la prévision de température maintenant
j'attire votre attention sur le 34
degrés qu'il fera à bordeaux et 34 à
agen et non pas 24 une toute petite
erreur ailleurs très beau temps et très
grosse chaleur
le tour de france à la voile demain
c'est l'étape la rochelle royan une
belle arrivée la mer sera belle le vent
soufflera de l'est force 2 à 4 enfin
notre éphémérides pour demain avec les
heures de lever du coucher du soleil et
la fed et julia
jacques merino vous présentera le
dernier journal vers 23h10 l'invité
d'antenne 2010 demain 12h 45 sera le
professeur paul millièmes l'un des
fondateurs de la fondation précisément
de la recherche médicale
merci de votre attention bonsoir